[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES:
Hello, everyone.
Thank you very much for coming
to our talk, bright and early.
And thank you to everyone
who's watching this on YouTube
because they had a little
too much fun last night.
So we're here to talk to you
today, about Cloud Audit logs
and using them to manage
your insider risk.
About us, we're both product
managers on Google Cloud.
My name is Marie Cosgrove-Davies
and I work on Stackdriver,
with a focus on logging.
JOSEPH VALENTE: And my
name's Joseph Valente,
and I work on security
with a focus on logging.
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES: And
we work together quite a lot,
at the intersection of
security and logging, which
is audit logs.
We'll be showing you
Stackdriver today,
so a little bit of an
intro on Stackdriver.
It's a SaaS ops
suite from Google,
used by app devs and operators
to monitor and troubleshoot
their applications on
GCP, on AWS, and on-prem.
And our mission
at Stackdriver is
to help developers
and operators keep
hybrid and multi-cloud
apps fast and available.
Stackdriver has a
number of components,
including an APM suite, made up
of Trace, Debug, and Profiler,
as well as an error
reporting tool.
What we'll be focusing on today
are the Monitoring and Logging
portions of the
Stackdriver platform.
And we'll specifically be
talking about audit logs,
like it says in the
subject of the talk.
There are three types of audit
logs that we may be discussing,
or will be discussing.
The first is admin
activity audit logs.
Now, these are always on
and always free for the GCP
services that produce them.
And they tell you about
the creation and deletion
of resources.
The second type of audit logs
is data access audit logs.
These logs tell you about
data reading and writing
and you must turn them on.
If you think about your
usage of the cloud,
you read and write data a lot
more than you create and delete
resources.
So these logs may
be very high volume,
and we'll talk a
little bit about how
to manage that volume.
And the third type of audit logs
is access transparency logs.
And these tell you when Google
support or Google engineers
access your resources.
These logs must
also be turned on,
and they're available to
platinum and gold customers.
Just a little note
on retention--
admin activity audit logs
are retained for 400 days.
Data access and access
transparency audit logs
are retained for 30 days.
And we'll show you how
to set up longer term
storage for your logs
as part of this talk.
So what are we going
to cover today?
We know that managing
insider risk requires more
than great logging, but you
can't manage insider risk
effectively without having
a functional and effective
logging solution.
So we're going to help you
with that building block.
We'll go through the basics
of how to use audit logging.
We'll go through some practical
tips and more advanced
use cases on using
audit logging on GCP.
And we'll do it all
in the framework
of a case study of a group that
used audit logs to effectively
manage their security on GCP.
And so here's our
real world example.
These are my cats, and
they have two hobbies.
Hobby number one is
napping and hobby
number two is being admired.
And pretty recently, I
stopped working from home
and I started working
from an office,
and suddenly, their
admiration supply
dwindled because I wasn't
looking at them all day
and telling them
how cute they were.
So they knew they had to
go seek more admiration.
And these are pretty
business savvy cats.
They're very up on
the technologies,
so they decided to start a
cat photos website on GCP.
As with any startup, each of
the cats had a special role.
Hollis was the cat
executive officer.
Acorn was the cat
marketing officer.
And Ash, who's the most
tech savvy of the three,
is the cat technology officer.
Now, as the CTO, Ash is the one
making most of the decisions
around security and
technology, so we'll
be following her today.
And Joe is going to tell
you about starting on GCP
and Ash's exploration of the
admin activity audit logs.
JOSEPH VALENTE: Thanks, Marie.
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES:
The demo, please.
JOSEPH VALENTE: Thanks.
So we're going to jump into our
Google Cloud Platform Console.
And now, Marie has a lot
of confidence in her cats,
but they are cats,
so we just want
to make sure that everything's
been set up properly here.
So we're in our
cat entrepreneurs
project, which is the
project that the cats created
to run their website on GCP.
We're going to jump
into our logging console
here in Stackdriver Logging.
Now, admin activity audit
logs are owned by default
for all services
that produce them.
What does this mean?
It means that if you create or
delete a resource, for example,
a GCS bucket,
we'll automatically
create a log of that for you and
store it for free for 400 days.
Those logs can't be deleted.
So if someone
inside your company
is trying to cover
up something that
happened at work by deleting
the log, that won't be possible.
So let's go ahead and
select the GCS bucket
and we'll go ahead
and select the admin
activity logs for that bucket.
I'm going to go ahead and
select all of the admin activity
logs going back over time.
Now, what I can see here--
this is how you know it's
real, is that it's taking
a little bit to load.
What I can see here
is that I've got
a list of all of the creates
and deletes that happened
to my resources on GCP.
I can see who did them.
I can dive in here and expand
these all to see a little bit
more information.
Now, I want to stress that while
you do get the admin activity
logs for write activity,
things like creates,
deletes, updates, you don't
actually get admin activity
logs for reads, in respect
of your admin metadata.
What that means is if someone
goes ahead and reads the access
control list on a GCS bucket,
you won't automatically
get an admin
activity log of that.
You'll need to turn
those on separately.
And we'll cover how to do
that in the second section
of this talk.
But what you will get is if
someone deletes a bucket,
you'll automatically
get the log of that.
And you don't need
to turn those on.
And as you can see here, we
get a bunch of information
that's useful for
auditing what happened
in this particular action.
So I can see that it was
Marie who did the activity.
There's an audit log created.
And she had permission
granted from this permission,
and this was the
action that she did
and the IP that she did it from.
So that's admin
activity audit logs.
An now, we'll cut
back to Marie, who's
going to talk a little
bit more before we
go into detail on how we can
turn on other types of logs.
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES:
So it turned out
that cat photos on
the internet were
a hugely underserved market.
The cats are business
geniuses, and so they
need to scale their business.
They have to hire.
And they look around and they
find this great engineer,
whose name is Sherlock.
You can see him right here.
He has a lot of experience in
the cloud, but he's new to GCP.
So he's learning.
And what Ash realized is that
as they're scaling the business,
this is the right
time to make sure
they have all of their
security set up so that they're
logging everything they need.
They have their long-term
log storage set up.
Just to make sure that in
case of anything happening,
they were prepared
to deal with it.
And Joe's going to show
you how that happened.
JOSEPH VALENTE: Awesome.
Thanks, Marie.
So in this section, we're
going to talk a little bit
about enabling data
access and admin read--
audit logs and exports.
Going to jump back to the demo.
So I'm back in my Google
Cloud Console on my home page.
If I head to the navigation
menu and I scroll down
to the IAM and
Admin section, I can
see that there's an option
to select Audit Logs.
If I jump in here--
I'm going to zoom out a little
bit because of the resolution
on the screen.
Hopefully, you can
all still see that.
Yes, great.
So what can I see here?
These are all the services that
I've enabled on Google Cloud
Platform.
So I'm using Cloud
Datastore API as an example.
Or I'm using Cloud Key
Management Service.
Now, I can scroll
through this list
and I can see all of the
services that I have enabled,
and I can individually configure
my audit logging for each one.
So I'm going to go ahead and
select this Cloud Composer API.
And I'm going to
go ahead and turn
on those admin read audit
logs that I was talking about
before.
So those are going
to give me the read
activity of all the
administrative-related metadata
on this service.
So if someone read an
access control list,
I'll now get an
audit log of that.
What about data reads
and data writes?
I can go ahead and
turn those on, too.
So these will now generate audit
logs whenever someone accesses
or writes data to the resources
that are inside the service.
So to use Google Cloud
Storage as an example,
again, I would now get an audit
log every time someone reads
or writes to a bucket on GCS.
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES:
And now you
remember that we said that these
might be pretty high volume
logs, so Joe's going
to show you how
to mitigate that a little bit.
JOSEPH VALENTE:
So you're probably
thinking at this point,
reading and writing
from a storage bucket on GCS
or from a database is going
to generate a ton of logs.
A lot of you would run
production systems that
face millions of
users, and every time
each one of those
users does an action,
it's probably going to read
from maybe one, if not more,
datastores on GCP.
And so as you can
imagine, the logs
pile up very, very quickly.
And so what you may want to
do is use the exempted user's
functionality to stop automated
accesses to that data.
So this is usually things
like service accounts
or other accounts that
on a regular basis
talk to other services at
a lower level inside GCP.
One example is you may have
a production front end that
has a service account that talks
to a database on the backend,
and he's regularly
pulling data out of there
and generating a ton of
data access audit logs.
You may not be as
interested in this activity
because it's not a human
actor, so it's not someone
from inside your company who's
going and changing and deleting
resources.
It's just the functioning
of your app, in general.
And you may prefer to have
other analytics in place that
are less heavy duty that
collect the information to do
with this stuff.
So what you can do here is you
can click this Add Exempted
User button and you can insert
the name of whether it's
a person or a service
account into this box,
and you can exempt them
from certain log types.
I'm not going to go ahead
and enable this just now,
but what I will say is
that you should be careful
when you use this feature.
And the reason is that if
you add an exempted user
to this box, they won't
generate audit logs.
And so you need to
make sure that you
have appropriate security
controls in respect
of that user.
For example, you have
a service account.
You know that it generates
a lot of audit logs.
And so you say, I'll add it
to the exempted users list.
You add it to the
exempted users list.
But all the people who
work for your company
have access to that
service account
and can grab the credentials
for it and SSH into it
and do whatever they want.
So now what you've done is
you've created a situation
where lots of people can
go ahead and do things
with service account
that won't be logged.
So we have a couple
of other talks
on securing service accounts
you can look up on YouTube--
that happened yesterday.
And you can find
out more about how
we've got security
features in place that
help you secure those accounts.
And we've just
released recently,
at GCP Next, a new feature
called binary authorization
that also helps around
securing service accounts,
but I'll let you guys look
that up in your own spare time.
So I want to click
on this button
here that says Default
Autoconfig, as well.
I want to talk a
little bit about this.
You're probably thinking there's
a huge list of services here.
What happens if I configure this
on Monday, and then on Tuesday,
someone goes and starts using
a bunch of new other services
that I didn't configure
audit logging for?
Do I have to just keep going
back and configuring new audit
logs for those services?
And for that, we've created
this feature called the default
autoconfig.
So you can click on
this button at the top.
It's going to send
you to this page.
This essentially allows you
to configure audit logging
for all the services.
So even when a person starts
using a service you've never
configured before, you can just
select this default autoconfig,
save it, and then that
service will automatically
have those logs enabled
when people start using it.
So you can see here, there's
a tool tip that says,
these logs are enabled as part
of the default autoconfig.
So that's a useful
feature, as well.
The last thing I want to touch
on, but I won't demonstrate,
is organization
level audit logging.
So the configurations
for audit logging
obey the inheritance
of our IAM system,
so if you create
an audit logging
config at an organization
level and you say, everything
in my organization,
log everything
for every service, that will be
inherited down by the projects.
And so you'll see a
tick here that says,
these logs have been enabled as
part of the organization level
config.
So that's available
to you as well.
You'll need to do
that using our APIs.
You'll need to pull down the
IAM config for the organization
and enable it there.
So that is how we enable
data access and admin read
audit logs on GCP.
And now I'm going to jump
to Stackdriver Logging
and show you a little bit
what we can do with those.
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES:
So one other thing
Ash wanted to make
sure she set up
was exports, because
as we mentioned,
your admin activity logs
are retained for 400 days,
but your other audit logs
are retained for 30 days.
So if you want to
keep them or you
need to keep them for
compliance reasons,
you can export them to
GCS for long-term storage,
or to BigQuery, if you
want to keep track of them.
And so Joe's going to
show us how that happens.
JOSEPH VALENTE: Great.
So I'm back in
Stackdriver Logging.
And I can see now I've
selected this data access
type of audit logs.
And I can see all the
data access operations
that are happening in
respect to this bucket.
So there's a bunch
of list operations.
Those are when
someone says fetch
me a list of all the files
that are in this bucket,
you'll get an audit log
of the list operation.
And I can see that there've
been different people who've
been doing that at my company.
So as Marie said,
we're only going
to hold onto these
audit logs for 30 days.
You're going to want to
do a whole lot of things
to these audit logs.
You're going to want to
use them in other tools
that you have set up and other
processes inside your business.
You're going to
want to export them
because you want to store
them for longer than 30 days.
In some way, that's
a bit cheaper.
So we've got this export feature
inside Stackdriver Logging
that allows us to do that.
You can just hit this Create
Export button at the top
and it will export whatever
you have in this filter here.
So right now, I'm exporting
all the GCS bucket logs
that are of the
data access type.
But I'm actually going to want
to export all of my GCS bucket
logs, so I'll change the filter.
And my export will now
work off this new filter.
So in order to do this, we need
to create what's called a sync.
So this sync is like
the point of integration
with Stackdriver Logging.
So I'm just going
to call it sync.
I'm not a very creative person.
So I'm going to
export into a service,
and we support three
different exports.
The first one is BigQuery.
Why would you want to use
BigQuery to analyze your logs?
So as you can see here,
in Stackdriver Logging,
we've got a pretty
robust user interface
that you can use to
analyze the logs.
We showed before about
how you can click through.
You can do searches and
filters up here at the top.
Where BigQuery becomes
useful is if you
want to join multiple
data sources together.
So you may have a
data source that
has the organizational
chart, for example,
of the people at your company.
Or you may have a
data source that
has a list of metadata
fields for each of the data
sources at your
company that specifies
what is high sensitivity
versus low sensitivity.
Whatever that may be, you
may have these different data
sources and you want to
draw them all together.
And you want to run a query
that says, show me everything
that people who work in
my reliability engineering
team who have access to the
user data inside my company
have done in the last 30 days.
You can run that sort of query
in BigQuery very, very easily.
So that's why you might want to
export you logs into BigQuery.
Cloud Storage.
So this is the second type
of export that we can set up.
Cloud Storage is very
useful for storing logs
for a long period of time
for archival purposes.
So once we have the
sync set up, it's
going to start drawing
all the audit logs out
of our Stackdriver
Logging console
and into Cloud
Storage as a copy.
As Marie said, the
data access audit
logs are only
stored for 30 days,
whereas once they're in Cloud
Storage, they just sit there.
And you just pay the
Cloud Storage rates,
which are very, very cheap
for storing this kind of data.
So once you have them
in Cloud Storage,
we're going to touch
a little bit later
on some security features you
can enable there to make sure
that people can't just go in
and delete the logs very easily.
But you can essentially
set them there
and it's one less thing
you need to worry about.
You'll have all of your logs
backed up to a cheap location.
And then if-- hopefully,
this doesn't happen--
but if an incident
happens down the track
and you discover that something
happened two months ago,
or 10 months ago,
or a year ago, you
can just go, hit that
Cloud Storage bucket,
pull up a copy of your logs,
and perform any forensics
that you need to.
One thing that a
lot of people do
is they may store it in
the Cloud Storage bucket
and then if you need
to do advanced analysis
of these logs, grab
them from Cloud Storage,
throw them into BigQuery,
and then do the analysis you
need to do there.
And then finally, we've
got Cloud Pub/Sub.
Cloud Pub/Sub is really useful
if you have a tool that you
might use regularly, like
a Sim tool or similar,
that you have on-site
and it's collecting,
let's say, all the logs from
your on-premise environment,
all the logs from your
other cloud services,
and the logs from GCP
that you might be using.
And you just want to pipe
your audit logs directly
into that tool because
you don't want to have
to set up a new process.
You just want to bolt it
on your existing process.
That's where Cloud
Pub/Sub is super useful.
So you create a
Cloud Pub/Sub sync.
We grab a topic.
And you can subscribe to that
topic from your other tool.
And every time a new
event is created,
it'll just pull it
into that new tool
and you don't have
to worry about it.
So that's exports and they're
a fairly useful and powerful
feature that we support
inside Stackdriver Logging.
We'll talk a little
bit more about them
later on in the deck, but I'll
just hand it back to Marie
now so we can talk a little
bit about some other stuff.
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES:
Now, as many of you know,
you're on-call.
And Ash is also on-call as
one of the two engineers
currently on the team.
And one day a page
woke her up from a nap.
The photos on the cat website
site weren't rendering,
and that's their main business,
so it's a pretty big problem.
And so she went to the GCP
console to investigate.
Now, Ash knows that naming
is one of the hardest
things in software.
And she solved the problem,
so all of the photos
are in a Google Cloud
Storage bucket that's
called Very Important Bucket.
Can go back to the demo, please?
Thank you.
JOSEPH VALENTE:
Highly secure name.
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES:
Highly secure.
So if we go into
Google Cloud Storage,
her first step is
going to be looking
to see if the bucket's there.
And it looks like it's not.
Now, if she didn't
know about audit logs,
she wouldn't really be
able to troubleshoot.
But since she does and she's now
very well-versed in audit logs,
she's going to go into Logging.
And she's going to take a look
at these GCS bucket audit logs.
And we're specifically concerned
with the admin activity
audit logs because that's
where a deletion would show up.
So it looks like there was a
delete operation on our Very
Important Bucket by
Sherlock, who is still
learning how to use GCS.
So he must have
accidentally deleted
the most important
bucket for the cats.
And now, since there's no
alerting setups to their chat
channel or email
alerts set up, he
didn't realize it was a problem.
Ash got paged.
So there are a couple
of things that Ash
is going to want to do.
First, she may want
to set up an alert
to let her know, via chat,
or via email, or even a page,
if this bucket is removed again.
And second, she
might want to see
if there's anything
else that Sherlock might
have done accidentally
because he's still
learning the platform.
So let's do that
second one first.
And if we click
on this, we'll be
able to show matching entries.
And you'll see that
our search field
has expanded from a single line
to our more advanced search.
What we really want
to look for here
is we'll remove the
GCS bucket, because we
want to look at
all of the activity
that Sherlock has been doing.
And a lot of creation
and deletion,
but also, this one--
set IAM policy,
which is a little suspicious.
So we can go down and
see who Sherlock's
been giving access to.
Let's see.
He gave Cloud Functions
access, and Dataproc
access-- all this access.
To whom?
Oh my gosh, to
sneakyspycat@gmail.com.
He must have been phished.
He's still learning.
But this is something
else that Ash might
want to set up an alert for.
So if we want to set up, for
instance, an alert for deleting
our Very Important Bucket,
we're going to do the same Show
Matching Entries.
So we're searching for delete.
Searching for Very
Important Bucket.
Going to remove
Sherlock because anyone
might delete this bucket.
And so now, we've got our logs.
We have our filter set up.
And what we're going
to do is create
a metric that will allow
us to alert on this problem
through Stackdriver Monitoring.
Gosh, lots of people have
been deleting this bucket.
Who would do that?
So we will call this Very
Important Bucket Actions.
We'll actually
make it a new one.
And we'll go ahead and
create that metric.
So now if we go over to
our Stackdriver Monitoring,
we can go into Alerting,
and we can create a policy
based on this metric
that we just defined.
So we'll add our condition.
We want a metric threshold,
so we'll select that.
And because I work
on Stackdriver,
I know that these
metrics are going
to be called logging/user.
So all of what are
called log-based metrics
in Stackdriver will show
up Stackdriver Monitoring
as logging/user and then
the name of the metric.
So we're looking for a Very
Important Bucket deletion.
And what we want to do is
alert if this is above zero.
Now, there's no data available
for this elected timeframe
because I just created
this metric and no one's
deleted the bucket since.
So that's good.
So I'll go ahead and save this.
I will add an email
notification to
cattechnologyofficer@gmail.com,
which shockingly was available
when I added it for this demo.
And then we'll name it, Very
Important Bucket is gone.
And so now, I'm not going to
go ahead and create and delete
the bucket, but if I did,
this is what my alert
would look like in Ash's email.
So it'll tell me what
happened and it'll
give me a link to the Cloud
Console to go investigate.
So now Ash is starting to set
up a lot of different alerts
on various security things.
And what she quickly realized
is that all of these alerts
are really digging
into her napping time.
Remember, the cat's
two favorite things
are napping and being
admired, and this website
is covering the admiration,
but napping is tricky now.
So what the cats
really need to do
is to automate their security.
They have to start seeing
what the common problems are
and how they're
consistently solving them.
And then writing some
automation to handle those so
they can stick to napping.
And so this is what Ash did.
And this is a simple
example of how
to automate some of your
security using Cloud Functions.
So Joe told us a little
bit about setting up syncs.
And in this case,
Ash has noticed
that everyone's supposed
to apply a label to all
of their prod machines
when they spin them up,
but that's a really hard
thing to remember how to do.
So she wants to
automate it so she
can stop going back and
adding them postemptively.
So the first thing is to
go to the Logs browser.
And she's going to
define a filter.
And actually, I've
got a pre-baked cake
in the oven that is an
export, so I will just
show you the filter
we've already defined.
And what this is
going to do is it's
going to tell us
about when we have
a new VM in Compute Engine.
So it is an admin activity log,
that's what the top line is.
And we're inserting a
Compute Engine instance.
And anything goes here.
And we've called this
audit log new instance,
and it's a Cloud Pub/Sub topic.
And so every time we create
a new VM in Cloud GCE,
we'll get a message
to the Pub/Sub topic
and we will trigger
our Cloud Function.
So if we go over
to Cloud Functions,
we've got this function
called Add Label to New.
VMs and it's looking at the
audit log new instance topic.
And if we take a look at it,
nothing has happened lately, .
But we can see the trigger
type is Cloud Pub/Sub.
The topic is audit
log new instance.
And you can't view the
source, but I swear,
this will add the label
end of prod to a new VM.
And so let's go take a look
at that and see if it works.
JOSEPH VALENTE: We copied
the source directly
from Stackdriver [INAUDIBLE].
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES: So
we'll create a new instance.
It will be called instance
seven, because again, we
are very good at naming.
We'll make it super tiny.
And Create.
So if I take a look at
this instance right now,
then I would expect
it to have no labels.
If I can load it.
Welcome to live demos--
there we go.
Oh, it already applied.
Anyway, if I had managed to open
it before my very quick Cloud
Function applied, we would
have seen labels, none.
But now the Cloud
Function has kicked in.
It's applied this
end of prod label.
And the cats have
managed to automate away
this task that was taking
them 10 minutes of napping
time a day.
And so that's a lot
more napping, all told.
And this is just a
very simple example
of a really powerful
and complex capability
that you have with
audit logs, which
is you can automate all sorts
of challenges or security
or non-security-related.
Can we go back to
the deck, please?
So what else might you want
to automate using these?
Oh, we're missing a slide.
Oh, well.
So you might want to
automate something
like checking to see if new
users are part of your org,
and removing their ability to
do anything, if they're not.
You might want to
automate adding
firewall rules to new VMs.
This is a super powerful
tool that you have available.
So now that the cats have
automated their security,
they're able to nap.
They're able to be admired.
And they know their
site is secure.
So it's a really
happy ending, which
I don't know how many
of you work in security,
but these are really rare
in the security space.
So everything is
great, and now Joe's
going to tell you a little more.
JOSEPH VALENTE: Thanks, Marie.
So everyone loves napping.
Everyone loves
getting admiration.
In order to do
that, obviously, we
need to keep pairing
up our security
practices to free up our
time to allow us to do that.
So today we've
covered audit logs.
We've covered how important they
are as part of your security
strategy.
One thing we have had
a few of is sometimes
we get a frantic call from
a customer saying, help,
something's happened and I don't
have data access audit logs on.
Is there any way you can
recover the data access
audit logs that would have
been generated 60 days ago?
And unfortunately,
the answer is no.
So the audit logs get generated
when you turn them on.
And so you need to make
sure that you have these
on in advance.
It is a little bit of
work, as we saw before.
It takes a few minutes, but the
investment is well worth it.
You get them set
up ahead of time.
You have a process where you're
storing them and archiving
them.
And it's a really great
insurance policy in the case
that something does
happen and you just
need that extra information.
The other one is having
teams and processes in place.
So it helps to
have great tooling.
It helps to have people
who are trained to use it.
And if you don't already
have that in place,
you should get that set up.
Auditing things
on a regular basis
and clearing through them
with an established process
is a lot easier than going
back later on and trying
to set it all up at
once when you realize
that something is amiss.
And finally, maturing only
once you've automated.
So you don't want to go ahead
and start automating everything
well ahead of time
because you think
it's going to be a problem.
See how you go first, see what
you're doing repetitively,
and then invest the time
into automating that.
So we also wanted to talk a
little bit about compliance
with audit logging, as well.
Obviously, using audit logs for
security reasons is a big use
case, but you may have
a compliance standard
or your own internal
policies that you
need to comply with, as well.
So what can you do to
make compliance super easy
using audit logs?
The first one is using
aggregated exports.
And we'll dive into exactly
how this works later,
but aggregated exports allow
you to export all the audit
logs for all your projects
in your organization
into a bucket.
And that's going
to be really useful
if you need to archive them
for a long period of time.
Like we said before,
GCS is very cheap.
Great way to archive your logs.
And they've just announced
a new bucket lock feature
that can give you some
additional security
to make sure the logs are even
more tamper-proof than they
were before.
You should obviously
have them in a GCS
bucket that has a really
strict security policy on it.
You don't want to
have it so that anyone
can access the bucket.
But the bucket lock
feature gives you
additional security
features that
allow you to lock it
down even further.
You can read more about that
on the GCS documentation.
So aggregated exports-- what
are these and why would we
want to do them?
So an aggregated
export is where you
export all the logs for all the
projects in your organization.
New projects get
automatically included.
There's a command here--
we won't run this
because if we run it,
it'll do an aggregated export of
every single project at Google.
And that will just set
the data center on fire.
But what you can
do is you can run
your own version of
this aggregated export
on your own GCP organization.
MARIE COSGROVE-DAVIES:
And we do have really
detailed docs on aggregated
exports and how they work.
So if you search for aggregated
exports, Google, Stackdriver,
you'll turn those up.
This is a really
common request we
get from users is,
how do I make sure
that new projects are covered
in my audit log exports?
And so we wanted to
make sure we covered it.
JOSEPH VALENTE: So head to
your favorite search engine.
I'm not going to
suggest which one,
but type in aggregated
exports, Stackdriver Logging,
and there's a full guide
on how you can set it up.
The query we have here
is just an example,
so obviously, it's not going
to work on your project,
but it's just a G Cloud command
that you can use from the SDK.
That'll set up the Stackdriver
aggregated exports for this org
and you'll get it
all into a bucket.
The last thing we
wanted to touch on
was access transparency logs.
So we did touch on these
a little bit at the start.
These are these logs
that you're going
to get if support access
your information for whatever
reason.
These are only available on GCP.
They're only available to
platinum and gold customers.
And they give you, basically,
visibility all the way
down the stack to even things
that engineering are doing.
So it just gives
you, again, plugging
that last frontier of
gaps that exist over
on the Cloud provider side.
Audit logs are great
for covering things
that happen inside your own org,
but if someone calls up support
and says to support,
hey, I'd like help
because I can't access
what's in this bucket,
this will make sure that if
support read the access control
list on that bucket, you'll
get an order log of that.
So let's just dive into this.
We've got an example access
transparency log here.
I'm going to just zoom
in to each of these bits
so we can talk through
what's inside each of them.
So at the top, you
obviously get the type.
You can see, it's an
access transparency log.
You get a little
bit of information
about the person
making the access.
You can see it was a
person who's usually
located in Canada, but
right now they're in the US
and they work for Google, LLC.
You get some information
about what happened.
So here, someone read the access
control list on the bucket.
We also have tooling that
stops support from reading
what's in the bucket.
But even if they read something
as small as a label on a VM,
or the name of a VM,
or the access control
list on a bucket, you will
get a log of all that stuff.
And then finally, the
reason why that happened.
So you can see here that you
open up a support ticket, case
number bar123.
You can go ahead and
grab that support ticket,
read everything that happened
in it, and think, yep,
this is kind of
what I would expect.
I was having trouble accessing
what was in the bucket
and support tech went and
checked the access control list
to see if I had
appropriate permissions.
So these are useful.
You can grab them.
They work exactly the
same as all the other logs
in Stackdriver Logging.
So all the things we've
just covered today
around setting up alerts,
setting up monitoring,
those are all covered.
You can use these as part
of an automation suite
with Google Cloud Functions.
Highly encourage you, if you
have platinum or gold support,
to get the set up and you
can start using them today.
So if you want to
learn more about audit
logs, just Google GCP
Cloud audit logging.
Super easy way to find
all of our documentation.
We've got some pretty
extensive documentation there
and we have some other
webinars that are on the web,
as well, that you can watch.
Or you can catch up on this
talk, if you're not already.
Awesome, thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]